you sure let's have it
thank you hi reject nation I'm Greg Alva
John's me so we're gonna watch the
trailer today for Margot Rob's but not
the terminal you don't want to get that
confused with that spur go classic this
is from the people who did I Tanya and
it has Simon Pegg and Mike Myers so you
know it's gonna be serious
let's check it out
visual whoa those are snakes oh [ __ ]
yes
pay raises for me pretty much yeah thank
you just water that's food
so wait
hey Dexter Fletcher season seven Jeremy
Irons
looks like one of those movies that has
a lot of style and attitude yeah yeah if
it doesn't get lost in that yeah let's
hope it also compensates with the well
thought out story for how complicated it
wants to appear I can already tell
people are gonna say Margot Robbie kills
it the visuals are great there's some
pacing and story issues in the film yeah
it's more visually stunning than it is
actually compelling and entertaining
that's what I'm worried about
I feel like you know when you see
trailers for I don't know
atomic blonde or associative yeah and
it's not that because I like the
approach of this character this
character seems like actually freaking
crazy her character seems like a
sociopath a psychopath and I'm excited
for that I think Margot Robbie plays
crazy women beautifully yeah maybe this
will be a better Harley Quinn movie
perhaps I totally think so I think that
she excels at doing like these weirder
types of roles and it's awesome to see
an actress like her who is just so
absolutely stunning like model status
who got famous for getting naked in the
wolf of Wall Street who can actually do
like really damn good character work you
know yeah thinking she I like that she
takes these different kinds of roles I
seems like every time she pops up she's
in a very different project you know
yeah
I appreciate that especially for her
longevity of her career you know it
makes me always interested to see what
she's up I'm not as pulled I feel like
the trailer I just get the impression
this movie's gonna be a lot more flashy
in style than will be truly entertaining
I get the impression I might get a
little annoyed while I'm watching this
movie to be totally honest I wonder I
mean it's been a while since I've seen
like a cool gritty British crime thing
but yeah just what they gave us in this
trailer was mostly like cool and
quotable stuff and not a heck of a lot
more than that to make me go this
movie's gonna be distinct in some way
beyond these stylistic elements yeah
yeah and when you when you advertise as
Simon Pegg and Mike Meyers are in this
movie I kind of would have liked to have
seen a little more what they're bringing
to the table here other than the fact
that they're in it likewise Mike Meyers
over
showing up in these kiri more serious
films as a pretty good you know yeah
well and that's funny too cuz cuz
inglorious basterds at least that was
supposed to be simon pegg and now here
they are together and they are still one
of them is the older and simon pegg you
know he's got his big Leo DiCaprio beard
I'm kind of confused on what this movie
is about
let me just read the IMDB description
here in the dark heart of a sprawling
anonymous city terminal follows the
twisting tails of two assassins carrying
out of sinister mission a teacher
battling of fatal illness and catch on
to that teacher battling a fatal illness
and enigmatika Anna turrets Mike Myers
and a curious waitress leading a
dangerous double life murders
consequences around the dead of night as
their lives all intertwine at the hands
of mysterious criminal mastermind
hell-bent on revenge yeah I feel like
this movie's gonna be a little bit over
complicated it's gonna have Tommy blonde
syndrome I don't know I mean I think
about this having read this synopsis is
now I think one of two things either
yeah this movie is trying to do way too
much stuff and it's kind of a mess or
they just don't know how to pitch it so
they're leading with all the stuff that
looks cool yeah you know all the neon
and all the you know exploitable
elements because it looks cool it looks
sexy and I imagine this movie gets
violent and those are all qualities I
like you know sex and violence sure I've
gotten to a point in my life where like
cool stuff is cool but I need a little
bit you know I need something to hook me
beyond you know maybe another trailer
could do that I don't know the main
thing that's hooking me right now is
Margot Robbie's performance mmm-hmm like
house several margot robbie driven
movies at baby news margot robbie cabal
and hey what else can you really say
right alright guys well thanks for
recommending this to us i saw a few
comments about this movie and i'm glad
we got to watch the trailer at least you
can subscribe to the real rejects if you
want you can click that notification
barrel if you dare and check us out on
patreon because it exists and check out
blind wave on patreon
so check out Tyrone Magnus on patreon
there's a lot of people on page stop
watching YouTube and just pledge to a
bunch of patron channels hey you're on
out the future you'll just kind of
select which things you want and you'll
just pay directly for them and that's
the end of that it'll be all owned by
Disney